un défi logo réussi pour le téléthon de
villepreux plus de 120 personnes ont
recréé le fameux logo de l'association
une image forte pour le lancement
départemental du téléthon sous le thème
de la hauteur à l'aérodrome de chavenay
villepreux aujourd'hui on a essayé de
faire plein de surprises et des belles
surprises sur le thème de la hauteur
donc là vous voyez on est entouré
d'avion et c'est merveilleux d'être
accueilli dans un endroit pareil
qu'illustre complètement le thème parmi
les multiples animations un simulateur
de vol où les participants pouvaient
voyager aux commandes de leur propre
avion tu es là san francisco je suis
allé à new york
allez c'était génial j'ai fait un voyage
fabuleux j'ai pris de la hauteur
donc pour aujourd'hui c'était génial
c'était vraiment dentelle un lancement
de la campagne en septembre avant le
téléthon 2010 9 des 6 et 7 décembre
deux cent cinquante mille bénévoles se
relaieront pendant 30 heures pour la
recherche contre les maladies rares
la réussite du téléthon tient à la
mobilisation de centaines de milliers de
bénévoles partout en france
et évidemment chacun d'entre eux a
besoin de temps pour organiser son
animation pour rassembler les gens
autour d'eux pour convaincre les
participants et d'autres associations à
les rejoindre dans cette belle aventure
granby à l'ensemble des bénévoles depuis
plus de 30 ans l'afm téléthon remportent
des victoires thérapeutique grâce aux
dons récoltés est consacrée à la
recherche dernière grande source
d'espoir la thérapie génique
[Musique]
e
vous